salut c'est confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs
et aujourd'hui je vous emmène très très
loin dans un pays qui fait rêver
direction la thaïlande ont paré
retrouver rémy vilains martinique est
connu dans le milieu du nautisme qui vit
et travaille depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années déjà
[Musique]
salut rémy on est très très loin
aujourd'hui on est en thaïlande
c'est combien d'heures de vol par
rapport à la martinique où il le faut
10h03 et boul oui c'est la nuit ah oui
parce que le point d'inflexion et thé
party pourquoi on n'est pas parce que la
thaïlande s'est pas tout près on n'y a
pas que c'est forcément comment t'es
venue l'idée de dire tiens je vais aller
voir c'était les vacances c'était
c'était quoi exactement
alors effectivement je suis allée la
première fois au championnat du monde
formule à en thaïlande
et cette occasion j'ai rencontré
tellement reste celle qui était un mois
max on y sert de contrepoids à l'époque
des civils distribués alors quel est le
rôle de rick hansen mairie refuse donc
la tri connaissance et puis elle comme
je marchais bien il m'a invité à
participer à l'économie
hilali ma façon d'approcher le problème
il ya des solutions et
ce jour il a commencé à quitter puisque
avant janvier 2007 santé avec une
gymnastique qui heureusement s'est bien
terminée et puis décide de changer
complètement et seulement lui l'arrière
sentir schots les venues musicale avec
anne alors ma mère ça tue le seul
fournisseur en france mon boulot à
l'époque on était là donc je dis il ya
exposé déduit comme les commencé à le
rolex bière l'a appelé le matin en me
disant voilà ce que cette offre là si tu
veux voilà une belle aventure une belle
rencontre qui a mené à cette belle
aventure qui dure depuis 13 ans des gens
en thaïlande
il ya une communauté française qui qui
qui s'installe de plus en plus je crois
en thaïlande a énormément de se refuser
ce plaisir les conditions de vie là bas
sont beaucoup plus intéressante qu'en
france avec avec la même somme le même
salaire qu'à kelly
on comprend mieux l'engouement justement
des français et notamment des retraités
qui viennent vivre là bas pour avoir
peut-être de meilleures conditions de
vie effectivement par rapport à ce
qu'ils avaient ce qu'ils avaient en
france la thaïlande c'est très très beau
c'est magnifique ça fait toujours rêver
quand on voit des images sur instagram
sur les réseaux sociaux de la thaïlande
quand on y vit c'est vraiment ça c'est
ces deux beaux paysages ses deux belles
plages c'est des gens sympathiques et
agréable
alors des cas c'est le pays du sourire
sa session les cantons très agréable et
bien obligés paysages qui sont de la
montagne ou de la plage bon je vais pas
dire que c'est l'union de ce classement
est très serré
si donc les jeux viennent même moi je
préfère la martinique
ce qui finit 10e la thaïlande et ont
retrouvé ceux ci y mirent en plus de ça
tout la beauté très agréable contact
exception et puis aussi luigi ex comment
ça se passe avec le coc u19 aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'en thaïlande
il ya un confinement qui est imposée ou
pas du tout est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
cas chez vous ou pas dès la première
alerte a envoyé tout le monde ce qui
concerne les jo n'ont pas c'est une
tradition et que tu es malade de la tri
qui m'agace c'est systématique
ces rentrées dans leurs gènes dont ils
ont pas problème déjà ce qui n'est une
longue barrière contre la propagation du
virus en question sont naturels ce soit
sur le terrain naturel deuxième chose
les gens vous disent bonjour ne
s'embrassera ne se servent à engraisser
plus tôt
alors les gars d'accord l'igas a nui à
distance contre son camp un énorme
avantage
c'est une autre approche et résultat des
courses il
la population qui on y va on a
énormément énormément de cas est
beaucoup trop de morts c'est que c'est
carrément une gestion et tant mieux
parce que du coup ça nous rassure un
petit peu pour les français qui vivent
en thaïlande
d'autant plus que bon bah ça aussi ça
fait partie des destinations qu'on va
rajouter à notre liste après quand tout
ça sera rentré dans l'ordre on sait pas
encore quand mais on en viendra avec
plaisir en faire un petit tour et on
viendra te voir pour faire ma planche
avec toi rémy mais en six ans plus tard
emilie c'est un plaisir de discuter avec
toi des échanges avec toi il nous fait
en découvrir un peu aujourd'hui la
thaïlande conviendra voir avec
énormément de plaisir prends soin de toi
surtout et puis à très très bientôt en
martinique
ces balades à vichy en insuffisance en
reste donc à la maison merci beaucoup et
demi à très bientôt
voilà c'est des cons finis d'ici et
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle qu'on se
retrouve en replay sur les réseaux de
martinique la première sinon ici même
demain à 18h45 d'ici là prenez soin de
vous et à très bientôt
m
[Musique]